[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjour qatar bonjour oriane et
cette semaine nous allons commenter la
semaine avec notre invité politique
roger karoutchi
bonjour vous êtes sénateur la république
un des hauts de seine alors on va revoir
le feuilleton de la révision
constitutionnelle on peut l'appeler
comme ça les consultations négociations
se poursuivent en vue de trouver un
accord sur le périmètre de la réforme ce
n'est pas gagné l'option du référendum
reste envisagée haute tension au sénat
sur le sujet des retraites agricoles le
gouvernement a eu recours à un vote
bloqué pour écourter le débat sur la
proposition de loi communiste pourtant
voté les communistes qui présentait
aussi à l'assemblée en séance leur texte
pour lutter contre la précarité
professionnelle des femmes
la proposition a été renvoyé à la saint
glinglin après une motion du groupe
majoritaire et sept semaines edouard
philippe a rencontré lé parlementaire
sur la révision constitutionnelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis lundi et jusqu'à mercredi
prochain edouard philippe reçoit les
présidents de groupes parlementaires
pour leur présenter elle la révision
constitutionnelle mais les mesures
concernant la réforme du parlement passe
mal tant dans un peu plus les relations
entre exécutif et parlement l'ancien
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy s'est d'ailleurs invité dans le
débat il était présent au sénat cette
semaine et ne s'est pas privé de lancer
quelques piques contre emmanuel macron
clément perreault entre l'exécutif et le
sénat le climat se détériore cette
semaine il est passé du nuageux à
l'orage eux le sujet qui fâche la
réforme de la constitution
lundi soir edouard philippe ouvre les
consultations des groupes parlementaires
mardi ce sont les élus communistes qui
sont reçues à matignon
surprise le premier ministre leur
dévoile son intention de limiter le
droit d'amendement en proportion de la
taille des groupes parlementaires
une annonce qui passe très mal un petit
groupe aurait un nombre d'amendements
limité et un grand groupe de députés
godillots pourrait disposer sans aucun
doute de centaines d'amendements qui ne
défendront d'ailleurs même pas en séance
et contingenté le droit d'amendement
c'est une aberration dans une république
est dans une démocratie comme la nôtre
sincèrement quelques heures plus tard
nicolas sarkozy est entendu au sénat
pour évoquer sa réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008
la séance est à huis clos mais les
parlementaires tweets et il en ressort
que l'ancien président a lancé quelques
piques à l'actuel une majorité forte
doit s'accommoder d'une opposition
puissante
on parlait de l'omniprésident
apparemment j'ai fait école
la réforme serait donc antiparlementaire
et ne ferait que renforcer les pouvoirs
du président le message est clair et
abondamment relayée par les
parlementaires les républicains jupiter
aimerais tu seul finalement qu'est ce
qu'il lui faut d'autres finalement
qu'une majorité qui est à sa main une
assemblée nationale qui est extrêmement
courtoise avec le président de
république et un gouvernement qui est
aussi à sa botte qu'est-ce qu'il veut
d'autre face à ces critiques le
gouvernement reste droit dans ses bottes
présent la république qui a été élu avec
un mandat un mandat avec le peuple
français croient que le sénat n'a au
canada
réa se replier sur lui-même à s'enfermer
dans le c'était mieux avant ou en ne
change rien je sais la volonté du
présent marché de poursuivre le dialogue
c'est celle du gouvernement et du
président aussi les parlementaires
socialistes ont eux été reçus ce matin
par le biais d'une consultation
populaire numérique
ils veulent faire des propositions pour
une réforme qui iraient dans le sens
d'un renforcement des pouvoirs
parlementaires qui en avaient leur fille
et consultant les parlementaires est ce
que ces parlementaires ont vraiment leur
mot à dire où ce ne sont que des
consultations de façade je suis assez
inquiet parce que pas très fort le cadre
même de la réforme constitutionnelle ou
ce qu'on veut mettre à l'intérieur de
cette réforme
ça a beaucoup changé en trois quatre
mois parce que j'entends bien monsieur
castaner dire il ya des engagements du
président la république
franchement je paul sentiment que
pendant la campagne présidentielle ou
même dans son discours devant le congrès
du parlement le président la république
est abordé la réduction du dorat
d'amendements l'inscription de la corse
dans la constitution
les trois mandats il a abordé la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires et
la thur on est prêts à discuter mais sur
le reste
chaque semaine nous apporte des éléments
nouveaux où on se dit qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent on veulent t'ils aller on a fait
la réforme de 2008
j'en sais quelque chose pour la voir en
grande partie conduite pour renforcer
les pouvoirs du parlement et c'était la
volonté de nicolas sarkozy d'avoir un
équilibre entre l'exécutif fort sur la
vème république et un parlement ayant
quand même capacité d'intervention
là on a le sentiment que sous couvert de
réformer les pouvoirs on veut en réalité
neutralisent elle parle et vous vous
demandez quoi concrètement quels sont
vos lignes rouges sur quels points tri
cela il ya plusieurs lignes rouges
la no nous avons déjà dit que nous
comprenions pas par exemple
l'inscription de la corse dans la
constitution ou je suis pour qu'on
avance sur un certain nombre de voix
parmi ce départ d'articles spécifiques
comme ce qui est envisagé par et
d'aurélien parce que ça ouvre la voie à
d'autres et dans quelles conditions et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
donc on l'avait refusée en 2008 qui a vu
un débat rappelez-vous rinck sur
l'inscription des langues régionales à
vous imaginer carrément une collectivité
donc ça c'est un peu compliqué deuxième
élément
on est prêt à discuter de la réduction
du nombre de parlementaires à condition
déjà de savoir comment la
proportionnelle c'est pas franchement
notre tasse de thé et on était prêt si
c'était vraiment marginale
ça ne se remettait pas en cause les
équilibres du scrutin mais quand
j'entends qu'on est à 15 20 voire 25 %
alors là vous tasser le si ces dépenses
et ckoi marginal quel est le seuil que
vous pouvez activer 10% public venait à
400 députés
et s'il dit à 30 ou 40 sièges à la
proportionnelle donc 10 pour franchement
ça me casse les pieds parce que moi je
suis un défenseur du scrutin majoritaire
mais on peut regarder s'il faut vraiment
faire en sorte que toutes les parties y
compris ceux qui au scrutin majoritaire
ne serait pas représentée puisse l'être
mais de là à dire que ça devait un
élément fort de la composition de
l'assemblée nationale non et enfin sur
les trois mandats successifs
on ne sait toujours rien c'est
interactif ou pas c'est ça concerne les
fonctionnaires ionale les fonctions
locales qui aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui
dans ce pays qui a un maire qui a été
élu parce qu'on rénove beaucoup qui est
un maître des lieux à 30 ans s'il est
content de son maire qui va dire au
maire écoutez monsieur l'effet trojan
dao revoir vous êtes en plein dans vos
investissements on veut pas savoir c'est
sur la lune rousse est libre choix des
électeurs de choisir quand même c'est le
minimum dans un pays démocratique et
respectant les droits du parlement
j'ai bien entendu ce que disait le
groupe communiste je partage entièrement
le droit d'amendement s'étendre à venir
et du est juste une question vous dites
il ya des lignes rouges mais vous êtes
quand même prêt à négocier sur certains
points est-ce que vous pensez que
l'exécutif est lui aussi disposé à
lâcher du lest le président larcher a
beaucoup discuté et sincèrement ici ou
là des parlementaires ont eu des
contacts avec matignon et de l'elysée
pour faire avancer les choses
ce qui me laisse un peu pantois pardon
de le dire comme ça mais c'est pas le
seul sujet la révision constitutionnelle
sur lequel on semble de temps en temps
avoir ça c'est que de semaine en semaine
on rajoute des points par exemple le
droit d'amendement
personne ne l'évoqué jusqu'à il ya
quinze jours donc c'est ça ou alors
c'est qu'ils veulent pas d'accord et que
c'est ouvre la discussion négociations
pour donner le sentiment de consulter
mais qu'au bout du bout
soit ils veulent passer en force soit
ils voudraient un référendum bien risqué
et je leur souhaite du bruit est ce que
vous avez aussi l'impression que le
sentiment qu emmanuel macron cherche à
faire le procès en conservatisme du
sénat sur cette réforme
oui parce que c'est le procès le plus
facile est une espèce de tradition
depuis 20 ans on dit la deuxième chambre
c'est représente trop les notables elle
bloque le système tout c'est un faux
procès tout le monde le sait puisque le
bicamérisme fonctionne plutôt bien moi
j'ai beaucoup d'amis députés qui disent
heureusement que le sénat corrige
souvent les textes de lois qu'on leur
envoie ils ont raison le bicamérisme
c'est la capacité de faire de bonnes
lois
alors après qu'il faille un travail
parlementaire plus liant plus rapide
moi je suis d'accord mais c'est pas ça
qui est l'objectif visiblement alors le
président de l'assemblée françois
d'origine lui espère qu'à contrôler sera
trouvée avec le sénat et sinon place au
référendum écoutez je dialogue d'ores et
déjà depuis plusieurs semaines avec le
président du sénat pour que nous
puissions arriver d'ici l'été à jean
n'en doute pas un texte commun qui
permettra d'avoir une réforme de la
constitution adoptée par le parlement
si jamais il y avait des blocages le
président de la république l'a dit le
gouvernement l'envisagent il peut
toujours y avoir un référendum sur
quelques points
est ce que vous pensez qu'au final le
président va recourir à l'armé du
référendum
franchement je lui déconseille je suis
pas là pour dire au président appuis
qu'il a à faire mais d'abord qu'il
réfléchisse bien ce qui se passe lorsque
matteo renzi en italie a voulu faire un
référendum sur les institutions il se
croyait à l'époque très puissant l'échec
du référendum a marqué le début de la
fin de matteo renzi beaucoup plus rapide
que prévu on se lance pas dans un
référendum institutionnel sans ceinture
et bretelles et donc là moi je vous
passe les bretelles et que la ceinture
et mal bouclé
parce que à force de vouloir mettre
beaucoup de choses dans le référendum
vous n'allez pas mettre un fin d'hommes
uniquement la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires ça c'est très populaire
monsieur organique suffit pourquoi le à
la révision constitutionnelle fait le
voter en poche et la mise en disant
voyez gérer du nombre de parlementaires
tout le monde est content macron nous
aussi la négociation est correct bon
voilà mais faire un référendum où vous
allez mettre la corse
nombre de parlementaires les trois
mandats le pouvoir d'amendement
attention attention de ne pas avoir au
fur et à mesure des jours qui passent là
le conglomérat des opposants qui seront
pas forcément sur la constitution mais
qui pourrait donner un verdict négatif
alors sur ce droit d'amendement puisque
vous en parlez roger karoutchi le droit
d'amendement
c'est un souhait d'edouard philippe 1
soit un petit peu surprise cette semaine
de restreindre le droit d'amendement
parlementaire en le conditionnant au
nombre d'élus par groupe
est ce que ce n'est quand même pas
logique de tenir compte de la
représentativité des groupes selon vous
non et franchement moins 2008 dans la
réforme
on a essayer d'encadrer le droit
d'amendement parce qu'on voulait à
l'époque essayait de faire en sorte que
les amendements par exemple présenté en
commission ne puisse pas l'être
forcément à nouveau en séance plénière
ce qui ralentit il dépeint mais il était
question jusque juste d'un encadrement
la vision du gouvernement et d'edouard
philippe 6 il la maintient sur il ya
plus de droits individuels en réalité
d'amendements mais c'est un droit
collectif de groupe
c'est une vision totalement inacceptable
totalement inacceptable parce que ça
veut dire en gros que le parlementaire
lui-même n'existe pas il n'existe qu'au
travers de ce serait piétiner ça veut
dire ça veut dire à tous que alcoa moyen
terme
tous les députés seront élus au système
proportionnel par les parties vous
revenez au système des partis
vous n'êtes pas dans un grand parti vous
ne pouvez pas influé sur le débat
parlementaire c'est une aberration enfin
et l'esquissé constitutionnel non non en
2008 par le congrès visent 8 le conseil
constitutionnel nous avait dit que le
simple encadrement papa pas limité par
go pain mais l'encadrement c'est à dire
le fait de pas pouvoir représenter un
amendement
ce n'était pas acceptable comment est ce
que le conseil constitutionnel pourrait
accepter que en réalité les
parlementaires perdent leur droit
d'amendement individuel sur un possible
on va passer à un autre sujet roger
karoutchi puisque la tension entre le
sénat et l'exécutif est montée d'un cran
cette semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en cause une proposition de loi
communiste sur la revalorisation des
retraites agricoles texte adopté à
l'unanimité en commission à l'assemblée
et au sénat mais dont l'exécutif ne veut
pas du moins pour le moment
il a donc demandé un vote bloqué
provoquant la colère des sénateurs et le
report de ce texte fabien becker celle
épilogue où le d'une séance rarement
vécu au sénat j'ai l'honneur en
conséquence de vous informer qu'en
application de l'article 44 alinéa 3 de
la constitution le gouvernement demande
à la haute assemblée de se prononcer par
un seul vote sur l'ensemble du texte
[Musique]
colère des sénateurs devant la manoeuvre
du gouvernement pour bloquer une
proposition de loi communiste sur la
revalorisation des retraites agricoles
déjà voté à l'assemblée nationale le
texte était pourtant sur le point d'être
adopté au sénat
mais quelques minutes avant l'examen des
amendements le gouvernement a coupé
court à la discussion
en dégainant l'article 44-3 qui permet à
l'exécutif d'imposer sa version du texte
procédure rarissime face à une
proposition de loi est inadmissible pour
le président du sénat est un moment on
débat de la relation entre gouvernements
et parlements être informés sept minutes
avant sept minutes avant la réunion de
la commission que finalement le
gouvernement allait déposer un
amendement est ce que ce fait partie du
respect entre le gouvernement et le
parlement
alors que les sénateurs dénoncent d'un
double coup de force contre le parlement
et le monde rural
selon le gouvernement la mesure n'était
pas financée à l'impulsion du
gouvernement est à la fois très
attentive à la question et petites
retraites du monde agricole mais en même
temps ne souhaite pas que ce soir un
nouvel impôt de 400 millions d'euros
soit créée comme ça sans cadre
budgétaire
après un rappel au règlement et une
suspension de séance
une conférence des présidents de groupes
se réunissaient en urgence deux heures
plus tard en séance le groupe communiste
reporter l'examen de sa proposition de
loi au 16 mai dans l'espoir d'ici là de
faire évoluer la position du
gouvernement
j'accorde si on a entendu des huées dans
l'hémicycle du sénat à l'encontre des
ministres c'est un fait rare un ace que
sur s'est passé cette semaine surtout
sénat est ce que ce qui s'est passé
c'est un peu la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase
oui parce que d'abord je rappelle que si
le 44,3 et évidemment dans la
constitution le vote bloqué exactement
le vote bloqué n'a été appliquée sur une
proposition de loi par un gouvernement
n'a pas été appliquée du moins par un
gouvernement sur une proposition de loi
depuis 1993 c'est à dire que ça fait 25
ans qu'aucun gouvernement n'a appliqué
ça moi je me souviens avoir fait sur
certains textes où certaines
propositions de loi des demandes de
retrait des demandes de 2,2 de vote
différé mais le vote bloqué qui veut
dire que seuls les amendements acceptés
par le gouvernement
voter sur une proposition de loi
d'initiative parlementaire
ce que je veux dire c'est que trop c'est
trop
le sénat comme l'assemblée nationale
peuvent avoir le sentiment que
l'exécutif n'a pas beaucoup de
considération pour le parle donc c'est
antiparlementarisme comme moi je trouve
que c'est c'est une succession et vas-y
je fais ça par ordonnance évasif je
consulte le parlement mais finalement je
lui dis bof eux je vous consulte mes
choses que je veux qu'ils aient bâtisse
à une réforme constitutionnelle juste ou
pas d'accord que le parlement gérard
ferrasse bien mépris du parlement de la
part de l'exécutif je ne parle pas de
mépris je parlerais plutôt de
méconnaissance de la culture
parlementaire méconnaissance du fait que
un bon débat c'est pas un débat en
accéléré en précipiter ou l'exécutif
décide et impose sans qu'ils aient de
possibilité de modifier les textes ça ça
n'existe pas dans une démocratie
alors on a changé de république et
démocratie mais dans la démocratie
parlementaire ou dans la démocratie semi
présidentiel de la vème république il ya
un beau parent exécutif fort et un
pouvoir parlementaire respecté et
aujourd'hui on a beau à exécuter fort et
un pouvoir parlementaire qui n'est pas
resté sur le fond de ce texte vous
demander au gouvernement de s'imaginer
vous imaginez ce qu'on demande c'est ce
que demandait le production de la
communiste voiliers sont pas sectaires
demandé à ce que les retraites agricoles
pour les non salariés passent à 85% du
smic enfin français manquent principe à
quoi ce serait une erreur de quand on
parle beaucoup de solidarité
quand on nous fait la leçon et où un
petit geste pour le monde agricole et le
monde rural qui est en telle
désespérance
franchement ça valait la peine de le
voter ce texte et de ne pas avoir
d'opposition d'ailleurs pardon madame
busin avait l'air bien embarrassé de
devoir annoncer ça la pauvre je la
plains c'est elle qu'on a envoyés pour
dire ça à l'assemblée aussi roger
karoutchi a eu beaucoup de tumulte et
une haute tension sur l'examen d'un
autre test présenté jeudi par les
communistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était une proposition de loi destinée
à lutter contre la précarité
professionnelle des femmes l'examen a
été très tendues en séance publique
le groupe mené par andré chassaigne a
dénoncé les rangs très clairsemés dans
l'hémicycle françois chevré les députés
communistes ont choisi le 8 mars pour
présenter leur proposition de loi sur la
précarité professionnelle des femmes
malgré la symbolique de la journée elle
n'a pas attiré foule de députés dont on
constate aujourd'hui alors qu'il ya un
débat extrêmement important
l'absentéisme je crois est
particulièrement important sur ces bains
qui souvent ça rentre le droit des
donneurs de leçons le groupe la
république en marche veut faire voter un
renvoi du texte en commission
c'est alors que les députés communistes
demandent à vérifier si le quorum est
atteint alors que rome c'est la moitié
des députés +1
je crois que là non plus il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté et quorum n'est pas atteint
après une suspension de séance de 15
minutes
les députés de la majorité arrive tu en
renfort la proposition de loi est bel et
bien renvoyé en commission
avez-vous bien conscience qu'en votant
cette motion de renvoi en commission
vous nous vous vous priver de la
possibilité d'améliorer le sort de
millions de femmes à temps partiel nous
sommes présents sur ces bons hommes et
femmes ensemble
le secrétaire d'état en charge des
relations que le parlement est ici à nos
côtés les ministres sont à leur boulot
travail donc un peu moins de démagogie
surtout en cette journée qui nous est
consacrée mettons nous au travail je
vous remercie les chances de rediscuter
ce texte en commission sont minimes
en tout cas pas avant plusieurs mois
roger karoutchi et ce qu'andré
chassaigne a eu raison de demander à
vérifier le quorum à dire le nombre de
députés présents en séance et
l'invisible ans et a pas grand monde sur
les bancs de la majorité
je ne jette pas la pierre parce que ça
nous est arrivé à nous du temps dans un
autre temps de demander des
vérifications de corne
la vérification de cormelles et dans la
règle dans le règlement du cem si ça ne
change pas grand chose qui change pas
grand chose au final surtout si vous
avez une interruption de terrain c'est
que pendant ce temps vous faites revenir
des parlements de verre donc en réalité
on la verrait sans question du quorum
elle n'est pas immédiate vous avez un
des lignes donc dans la pratique c'est
comment dire de la technique
parlementaire mais non mais en même
temps pardon de le dire et je vois que
là en revanche sur ce texte je castaner
était au banc ça veut dire que le
pouvoir exécutif a crû en juin juillet
2010 est qu'il allait avoir un parlement
docile et qui se rend compte que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile que ça de
traiter avec le parlement surtout si on
ne respecte pas on va pas devoir passer
à la partie politique de cette émission
roger karoutchi avec notre partenaire du
figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on accueille cette semaine mathilde
de sirop bonjour mathilde bonjour oriane
bonjour katia bonjour roger karoutchi
on va parler un petit peu de la droite
et de votre famille politique
les républicains vous savez il ya eu ces
propos polémiques de laurent wauquiez il
ya quelques semaines il a soupçonné
nicolas sarkozy d'avoir mis sur écoute
ses ministres est ce que vous regrettez
ces propos est-ce que vous pensez que
laurent wauquiez et nicolas sarkozy
peuvent se réconcilier
alors d'abord laurent wauquiez s'est
lui-même excusé en privé avec nicolas
sarkozy en public sur ses propos par
rapport à ces écoutes moi j'avais dit à
nicolas sarkozy écoute si tu m'as mis
sur écoute pendant que j'étais au
gouvernement avec toi franchement
je sais pas ce que tu as appris ce n'est
pas grand enfin bon c'était une
plaisanterie non je pense que
effectivement les excuses ont été faites
là tu ses chaussons réglé nicolas
sarkozy reçoit laurent wauquiez la
semaine prochaine voilà ils veulent tous
les deux tourner la page et passer à
autre chose
la relation entre l'ancien président de
la république qui est la référence quand
même à droite et l'actuel président des
républicains doit être d'une autre
nature si on veut avancer bien sûr sur
le plan de la stratégie politique est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec laurent
wauquiez qui s'adresse en grande partie
à l'électorat de la droite très radicale
jusqu'aux front national finalement
alors moi j'ai une position un peu un
peu particulière j'ai parrainer la
candidature de laurent wauquiez j'ai
fait campagne pour lui je voter pour lui
pour la présidence et en même temps en
j'ai accepté d'être conseiller politique
chez valérie pécresse dans le mouvement
libre pourquoi parce que autant je
partage la vision de laurent wauquiez
sur tous les éléments d'ordre régalien
sécurité immigration défense identité je
trouve que ce qu'il dit correspond à ce
que je pense et ce que je crois autant
sur certains sujets socio économiques
sociétaux je suis plus en adéquation
avec ce que dit valérie pécresse donc je
pense qu'on peut tous être dans le même
parti
avoir des positions ou des orientations
pas forcément identique sur tout
l'essentiel c'est qu'on se parle et
qu'on avance
alors si vous voulez dire par rapport
aux élections européennes à venir
est ce que c'est le positionnement de le
révoquer ou des positionnements plus pro
européen qui doivent être adaptées
on n'a pas eu encore de discussions à
l'intérieur on va la voir ce que vous
regrettez qu'en 2022 il ya un
affrontement entre deux lignes à droite
celle de laurent wauquiez et celle de
valérie pécresse
moi je suis très opposé ce qui et quoi
que ce soit en 2022 d'affrontements
parce que si vous avez le moindre risque
quand même pourquoi ce qui est selon
valérie pécresse dit moi je suis un
mouvement associé je suis l a redit je
suis dans le parti j'appartiens au
républicain je suis au bureau politique
des républicains au comité stratégique
des républicains je veux
avoir une identité avoir une
personnalité avoir une vision mais en
interne et c'est à mon sens ce qu'avait
fait préalablement nicolas sarkozy et
quand nicolas sarkozy était président
vous aviez alain juppé vous aviez
dominique bussereau vous aviez bruno
lemerle et tout le monde était là ça
veut pas dire que tout le monde était
d'accord sur tout heureusement
d'ailleurs
ça veut dire qu'on se parle est 8 heures
de la guerre des chefs
non je ne dois pas franchement elle nous
a coûté tellement cher que ou bien on
est débile au fait on évite donc je
pense qu'il faut d'ailleurs discuter et
se mettre bien d'accord et se dire
attention la ligne rouge c'est de pas
être débile
au point d'avoir deux trois candidats en
2022 ce qui nous écarterait du deuxième
tour
on sait que ça va comme ça les adhérents
et les électeurs ne l'accepterai pas on
se parle entre nous on détermine quels
mieux placé et une fois qu'on a
déterminé qu est le mieux placé je le
soutiendrai qui que ce soit sur le front
national qui se réunit en congrès tout
le week-end
marine le pen veut changer le nom de ce
parti est ce que ça peut changer quelque
chose selon vous pour ce pour ce parti
et pour cet ancien candidat ne sais pas
c'est pas une appellation qui change
même si effectivement tourné la page du
front national qui s'appelle comme ça
depuis 45 ans c'est sûrement quelque
chose qui politiquement va compter mais
ce sera sur le projet on attend de
savoir quel est le nouveau projet mais
en tout état de cause de ce que
j'entends alors on va voir ce qu'ils
aient déterminé de ce que j'entends
on change le nom mais c'est un
ravalement de façade on reconstruit pas
l'immeuble
merci beaucoup aussi russie merci
mathilde merci à vous et on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour une autre
revue de la semaine très bonne ces deux
programmes sur lcp public sénat
[Musique]